J'aimerais que vous pensiez
au troisième mot qui a été dit
à propos de vous
ou si vous accouchiez,
à propos de la personne que vous accouchiez.
Vous pouvez répondre si vous le souhaitez
ou le dire à voix haute.
C'était, les deux premiers étaient : « C'est un... »
Cela vous montre que je m'occupe
également de questions où il n'y a pas
de certitude de savoir si c'est une fille ou un garçon,
donc la réponse mixte était très appropriée.
Bien sûr, maintenant la réponse est souvent
non pas à la naissance mais à l'échographie,
à moins que les futurs parents choisissent
d'être surpris comme nous l'étions tous.
Mais, j'aimerais que vous pensiez
à ce qui mène à cette déclaration
sur le troisième mot,
parce que le troisième mot
est une description de votre sexe,
et j'entends par là,
faite par une description de vos organes génitaux.
En tant que pédiatre endocrinologue,
j'étais très, très impliqué,
je le suis toujours, d'une certaine manière
dans des cas où il y a des inadéquations
dans les externes
ou entre les externes et les internes
et nous devons littéralement comprendre
quelle est la description de votre sexe.
Mais il n'y a rien qui est définissable
au moment de la naissance
qui vous définit,
et quand je parle de définition,
je parle de votre orientation sexuelle.
Nous ne disons pas : « C'est un garçon gay. »
« Une fille lesbienne. »
Ces situations ne sont pas définies
avant la deuxième décennie de la vie.
Elles ne définissent pas non plus votre genre,
ce qui, différent de votre sexe anatomique,
décrit votre concept du soi.
Est-ce que vous vous voyez
comme un homme ou une femme
ou quelque part dans le spectre entre les deux ?
Cela se manifeste parfois
dans la première décennie de la vie,
mais cela peut être très déroutant pour les parents
parce que c'est assez normal pour les enfants
de faire semblant d'être du sexe opposé.
En fait, il y a des études qui montrent
que même 80 % des enfants
qui agissent ainsi
ne continueront pas
ce jeu
au moment où la puberté commence.
Mais, au moment où la puberté commence,
entre environ l'âge de 10 à 12 ans chez les filles,
12 à 14 chez les garçons,
avec le développement de la poitrine ou l'augmentation de deux à trois fois
des organes génitaux masculins,
à ce moment particulier, l'enfant qui dit
qu'il est absolument dans le mauvais corps,
est presque certainement transgenre
et est très peu susceptible de changer ces sentiments,
peu importe comment on tente la thérapie réparatrice
ou toute autre chose nocive.
Ceci est relativement rare,
j'ai eu relativement peu d'expérience personnelle avec ceci,
et mon expérience était plus typique seulement parce que
j'ai eu une pratique dans l'adolescence. J'ai vu quelqu'un de 24 ans,
passé par Harvard, génétiquement femelle, avec trois colocataires masculins
qui connaissaient toute l'histoire,
un registraire de l'université qui indiquait son nom sur les listes de cours
comme un nom masculin,
et vint à moi après être diplomé en disant : « Aidez-moi.
Vous savez beaucoup de choses sur l'endocrinologie. »
J'ai traité un grand nombre de personnes qui sont nés sans gonades.
Ce n'était pas sorcier.
Mais j'ai fait un marché avec lui : je vais vous traiter si vous m'apprenez.
Et c'est ce qu'il a fait.
Quelle éducation j'ai obtenue
en prenant soin de
tous les membres de son groupe de soutien.
Puis, je suis devenu très troublé, car je pensais
qu'il était assez facile à cet âge de donner
à ces personnes des hormones du sexe dans lequel ils s'affirment,
mais ensuite mon patient s'est marié,
et il a épousé une femme
qui était née comme un homme,
s'était mariée comme mâle, avait eu deux enfants,
puis était devenue femme.
Cette femme charmante était unie à mon patient,
en fait, ils se sont légalement mariés parce qu'ils sont venus
en tant qu'homme et femme, et qui savait ?
(Rires)
Et alors que j'étais troublé --
Est-ce que cela fait ceci et cela gay ? Est-ce que cela fait ceci et cela hétéro ?
je confondais l'orientation sexuelle
avec l'identité sexuelle.
Mon patient me dit :
« Écoutez, écoutez, écoutez.
Si vous pensez à la chose suivante, vous aurez tout compris :
L'orientation sexuelle est la personne avec qui vous allez au lit ;
l'identité sexuelle est la personne que vous êtes quand vous allez vous coucher. »
Par la suite, j'ai appris des nombreux adultes --
je me suis occupé d'environ 200 adultes —
j'ai appris grâce à eux que si je ne jetais pas un coup d'œil
à qui était leur partenaire dans la salle d'attente,
je ne pourrais jamais deviner
mieux que par chance
s'ils étaient gay, hétéro, bi,
ou asexuel dans leur genre affirmé.
En d'autres termes,
une chose n'a absolument
rien à voir avec l'autre.
Les données le prouvent.
Maintenant, comme je m'occupais de 200 adultes,
je trouvais cela extrêmement douloureux.
Ces personnes étaient -- beaucoup d'entre eux
ont dû renoncer à beaucoup de leurs vies.
Parfois, leurs parents les rejetaient,
leurs frères et sœurs, leurs propres enfants,
puis leur conjoint divorcé
leur interdisaient de voir leurs enfants.
C'était tellement horrible, mais pourquoi l'ont-ils fait
à 40 et 50 ans ?
Parce qu'ils sentaient qu'ils devaient s'affirmer
avant de se suicider.
Effectivement, le taux de suicide
chez les personnes transgenres non traitées
est parmi les plus élevés dans le monde.
Alors, que faire ?
J'ai été intrigué en allant à une conférence
en Hollande, où il y a des experts,
et j'ai vu la chose la plus remarquable.
Ils traitaient de jeunes adolescents
après leur avoir donné le test le plus intense
de psychométriques pour déterminer le sexe,
ils les traitaient en bloquant
la puberté qu'ils ne voulaient pas.
Parce qu'au fond, les enfants sont quasiment identiques,
jusqu'à ce qu'ils passent par la puberté ;
à ce moment-là, si vous sentez être dans le mauvais sexe,
vous vous sentez comme Pinocchio devenant un âne.
Le fantasme que vous aviez de voir votre corps changer,
d'être qui vous voulez avec la puberté,
est en fait annulé par la puberté que vous obtenez.
Ils s'effondrent.
C'est pourquoi mettre la puberté en attente —
Vous ne pouvez pas simplement donner des hormones à des gens aussi jeunes.
Ça limiterait leur croissance.
Vous pensez que vous pouvez avoir une conversation significative
sur les effets d'un tel traitement sur la fécondité
avec une petite fille de 10 ans ou un garçon de 12 ans ?
Donc, cela fait gagner du temps dans le processus
de diagnostic de quatre à cinq ans
pour qu'ils puissent y penser,
ils peuvent avoir de plus en plus de tests,
ils peuvent vivre sans se sentir que leur corps s'enfuit.
Puis, dans un programme qu'ils appellent 12-16-18,
vers 12 ans, c'est quand ils donnent les hormones de blocage,
puis à 16 ans avec de nouveaux essais,
ils se requalifient.
Rappelez-vous, les hormones de blocage sont réversibles,
mais quand vous donnez des hormones du sexe opposé,
les seins commencent à se développer
les poils du visage et la voix, en fonction de ce que vous utilisez
ces effets sont permanents,
ou requièrent l'intervention chirurgicale pour les retirer ou l'électrolyse
et vous ne pouvez jamais vraiment affecter la voix.
Donc, c'est grave, et ce sont des trucs de 15-16 ans.
Puis à 18 ans, ils sont admissibles à la chirurgie,
tandis qu'il n'y a pas de bonne chirurgie génitale pour femmes-hommes,
la chirurgie mâle-femelle a dupé les gynécologues.
C'est à quel point cela peut être bon.
J'ai donc regardé la façon comment allaient les patients,
et j'ai regardé les patients qui avaient l'air comme les autres,
sauf que leur puberté était retardée.
Une fois que je leur ai donné les hormones
en accord avec le sexe qu'ils affirmaient,
ils avaient l'air beaux.
Ils avaient l'air normaux. Ils étaient d'une taille normale.
Vous ne seriez jamais capable de les reconnaître
dans la foule.
Donc, j'ai décidé que j'allais le faire.
C'est vraiment là où le domaine de l'hormone
endocrine pédiatrique commence,
parce que si vous allez y faire face
chez les enfants de 10-12 ans, 10-14 ans,
Je me suis donc occupé d'enfants,
et c'est maintenant devenu la norme de diligence,
et l'hôpital pour enfants était associé.
En leur montrant les enfants avant et après,
les gens qui n'ont jamais été traités, les gens qui souhaitaient être traités,
et les photos des Hollandais, ils sont venus vers moi et m'ont dit :
« Vous devez faire quelque chose pour ces enfants. »
Où étaient ces enfants avant ?
Ils étaient dehors, en train de souffrir.
Nous avons donc commencé un programme en 2007.
C'est devenu le premier programme de la sorte --
mais c'est du genre hollandais --
aux États-Unis.
Depuis, nous avons eu 160 patients.
Sont-ils venus d'Afghanistan ? Non.
75 % venaient
des alentours de Boston.
Certains sont venus d'Angleterre.
Jackie avait été agressée dans les Midlands, en Angleterre.
Elle a 12 ans là-bas,
elle vivait comme une fille mais elle se faisait battre.
C'était un spectacle d'horreur. Ils devaient l'éduquer à la maison.
La raison pour laquelle les Anglais venaient était
parce qu'ils ne traitaient pas les gens
en dessous de 16 ans, ce qui signifie qu'ils étaient relégués
jusqu'à ce qu'ils soient adultes, quel que soit ce qui arrive,
même s'ils testaient positifs.
En plus, Jackie était
en vertu de marquage du squelette,
destinée à mesurer 1m65.
Cependant, elle avait juste commencé
la puberté masculine.
Eh bien, j'ai fait quelque chose d'un peu innovant,
parce que je connais les hormones,
l’œstrogène est beaucoup plus puissant
dans les épiphyses fermées, les plaques de croissance,
et l'arrêt de la croissance, que la testostérone.
Donc, nous avons bloqué la testostérone
avec une hormone de blocage,
mais nous avons ajouté l’œstrogène, non pas à 16 ans, mais à 13 ans.
La voici à 16 ans à gauche.
À 16 ans, elle est allée en Thaïlande,
pour la chirurgie plastique génitale.
Elle le fera maintenant à 18 ans.
Elle mesure maintenant 1m80
plus que cela, elle a une poitrine d'une taille normale,
grâce au blocage de la testostérone,
chacun de nos patients
a une poitrine d'une taille normale
s'ils viennent nous voir à l'âge approprié.
La voici tout à droite.
Elle a fait une apparition publique,
demi-finaliste au concours de Miss Angleterre.
Les juges ont débattu se demandant s'ils pouvaient faire cela.
Peuvent-ils la faire —
L'un d'eux a dit en plaisantant m'a-t-on dit :
« Mais elle a plus de naturel
que la moitié des autres candidats. »
(Rires)
Certains d'entre eux ont été réarrangés un peu,
mais c'est grâce à son ADN.
Elle est devenue une porte-parole remarquable.
On lui a proposé des contrats de mannequin,
elle me taquinait et elle m'a dit :
« J'aurais eu peut-être plus de chance
si vous m'aviez fait grandir jusqu'à 1m85. »
(Rires)
Allez comprendre.
Donc cette photo dit tout.
Cela dit vraiment tout.
Voici Nicole et son frère Jonas,
des jumeaux identiques,
ça a été prouvé,
Nicole s'est affirmée comme une petite fille
dès l'âge de trois ans.
À l'âge de sept ans, ils ont changé son nom,
et ils sont venus me voir dès le début
d'une puberté masculine.
Vous pouvez imaginer en regardant Jonas à seulement 14
que la puberté masculine commence tôt dans cette famille,
il ressemble plus à un adolescent de 16 ans,
cela souligne encore le fait que vous devez être conscient
où est le patient.
Nicole a fait un blocage pubertaire ici,
et Jonas est juste en train -- contrôle biologique.
Voici à quoi Nicole pourrait ressembler si nous ne le faisions pas.
Il a une prominente pomme d'Adam.
Les os de son visage sont angulaires, une moustache,
vous pouvez voir la différence de tailles
car il est passé par une poussée de croissance qu'elle n'aura pas.
Nicole est sous œstrogène. Elle a un peu de forme.
Cette famille est allée à la Maison Blanche, au printemps dernier
en raison de leur travail pour renverser une loi anti-discrimination,
il y avait un projet de loi qui pourrait bloquer
le droit des personnes transgenres dans le Maine
d'utiliser les toilettes publiques,
et il semblait que le projet de loi allait passer,
cela aurait été un problème,
mais Nicole est allée voir chaque législateur dans le Maine.
Elle disait : « Je peux le faire.
S'ils me voient, ils vont comprendre pourquoi je ne suis pas
une menace dans les toilettes pour femmes,
mais peux être menacée dans celles pour hommes. »
Ils ont finalement compris.
Donc, où va-t-on à partir de cela ?
Nous avons encore du chemin à faire en termes de lutte contre la discrimination.
Il n'y a que 17 états qui ont une loi anti-discrimination
contre la discrimination dans le logement,
l'emploi, le logement public,
seulement 17 états et 5 d'entre eux sont dans la Nouvelle-Angleterre.
Nous avons besoin de médicaments moins chers.
Nous avons besoin de cette condition hors du DSM
(manuel diagnostique et statistique des troubles mentaux).
Il s'agit autant d'une maladie psychiatrique
que d'être gay et lesbienne,
et on s'est débarrassé de cela en 1973
et le monde entier a changé.
Cela ne va pas changer le budget de quiconque.
Ce n'est pas si courant.
Mais les risques de ne rien faire pour eux,
non seulement les mettent tous en danger
de perdre leur vie au suicide,
cela dit aussi
si nous sommes une société véritablement inclusive.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)